Sophie Langlois.
(voix de soldats)
- Ce ci i i russe de chars
d'assaut était à 30 kilomètres
de la capitale, quand
les Ukrainiens ont attaqué.
Ces images ont été publiées
par l'armée ukrainienne, qui
a bien l'intention de prendre
les grands moyens pour défen
Kiev. Les soldats qui ont
préparé l'embuscade sont
fiers des résultats.
"Nous avons détruit
deux chars, dit-il, et tué
près de 30 soldats russes,
l l le commandant du convoi."
L'armée russe fait aussi
sa propagande en publian
cette vidéo censée montrer
sa progression sur le terrain.
Mais dans les faits, au sol,
les troupes de Poutine
piétinent. Kharkiv, que Moscou
pensait prendre rapidement,
n'est toujours pas tombée.
"Je ne doute pas que nous
allons atteindre nos objectifs",
dit Vladimir Poutine.
La Russie nie avoir bombardé,
à Marioupol, itititital
pédiatrique et une maternité.
Le ministère russe de
la Défense accuse même
des nationalistes ukrainiens
d'avoir orchestré une mise
en scène pour soulever
la colère de l'opinion
publique internationale.
Toutes les capitales
occidentales ont sévèrement
condamné l'attaque, qui a fait
3 morts et 17 blessés.
EMMANUEL MACRON,
président de la France
- La France condamne
avec la plus grande fermeté
ce qui est un acte de guerre
indigne et amoral.
- Le ministre russe des Affaires
étrangères était en Turquie
pour tenter de négocier
un cessez-le-feu avec
son vis-à-vis ukrainien,
sans succès.
DMYTRO KULEBA, ministre
ukrainien, Affaires étrangères
- "Il n'y pas eu de pr,,,,,,
dit le ministre, qui répète que
l'Ukraine ne va pas capituler.
Sergueï Lavrov affirme, lui, que
la Russie n'a pas l'intention
d'attaquer d'autres pays.
Et il lance cet avertissement :
"Les pays", dit-il, "qui arment l'Ukraine
devront porter la responsabilité
de leurs actes."
Ici Sophie Langlois,
Radio-Canada, Montréa